[Music]
the Rich Roll podcast
hey everybody Welcome to the podcast
today we're going to do something a
little bit different and I want to
preface this special episode with a bit
of context and introduction at the end
of 2022 as I reflected on a decade of
Hosting conversations over 740 to date
I expressed both extreme gratitude for
all that has transpired over the course
of this journey as well as this creative
urge to experiment because to my mind
podcasting really is still a new medium
and although there are of course strong
incentives to continue doing the show in
the way that I always have the truth is
is that there really are no rules I will
of course continue to host weekly
long-form conversations with the people
that most inspire me as I always have
but I do have this impulse to innovate
to try new things and and play a bit
with the format because stasis is death
and so two weeks ago marked the first
instance of this impulse in the form of
documentary style podcast in which my
roll-on Compadre Adam skolnik and I
spent the better part of a month
endeavoring to get our heads around the
rapidly developing world of artificial
intelligence perhaps the most powerful
and transformative technology to emerge
In Our Lifetime and to talk about what
it pretends good and bad for all of us
in both the short and the long term
creating that episode was interesting
putting it out was even more interesting
because it was met with a predictable
mix of both enthusiasm and lament many
people perhaps most appreciated it but
others were less enthusiastic and for
them I suppose it was sort of like
attending your favorite band in concert
expecting to enjoy the hits to instead
have to weather or sit through the new
album and I get that it's fine
but growth requires getting out of your
comfort zone to explore unchartered
terrain physically and mentally but also
intellectually and creatively this is a
current and recurring theme of this show
I can't just talk it I also need to
demonstrate it to live it myself to walk
it a walk that respects and nurtures the
inner spark even if it risks alienating
an audience or a portion of an audience
I've perhaps trained to expect something
different
growth requires the courage to scratch
the creative itch even in the face of
fear of how the result will be received
and turning that spark of inspiration
into something shared publicly is always
scary it's inevitable but allowing that
fear to mute one's voice is the death of
creativity it's antithetical to growth
it's at odds with both the person I
aspire to be and the sensibility I
strive to encourage in others and so
although it may not have been everyone's
cup of tea I'm really proud of the AI
episode it provided an opportunity for
Adam to flex his investigative
journalism muscles it presented A new
challenge in storytelling and it gave my
talented team a new and nourishing
creative opportunity to shine I suppose
this is all a long preface to saying
that today I am once again tiptoeing
venturing out into the unknown to try
something new
as I've previously mentioned on a number
of occasions I find the moments where
I'm speaking into a microphone alone
without a partner like I'm doing right
now or for example during the
introductions to my guests deeply deeply
uncomfortable and you know in many a
podcaster including my wife feel
absolutely at home doing this and
ironically given that I talk into a
microphone for a living this is not me
but rather than avoid or minimize this
discomfort I thought I would beat the
sphere head on
step out of my comfort zone a bit do
something I've never before done on this
show and for the first time
offer up some thoughts in monologue
format
okay so the subject of my thoughts today
focus on our evolving and complicated
relationship with the digital world met
with a call to action to reclaim or
innate Humanity to exert greater Agency
on how we direct our attention to
shoulder responsibility to live our
lives more present more connected and
with greater conscious intention
the internet as it exists today
specifically but not exclusively social
media is of course both a tool of
miraculous proportions and a highly
addictive distraction
on the one hand it presents a repository
of extraordinary knowledge at our
fingertips a source of inspiration a
device for self-betterment for community
building and this excellent lever to
organize and manifest positive change in
the world I myself have reaped its
benefits it's provided me with a
vocation previously not possible it's
allowed me to connect directly with an
astonishing number of inspiring people I
could have never before accessed and in
turn share that inspiration with others
and it's allowed me to build and
participate in a global community of
like-minded seekers and souls on the
other hand social media and in fact the
internet as a whole is almost entirely
organized around a business model that
deeply undermines its positive
attributes a superstructure owned and
controlled by a very small grouping of
corporate behemoths that prioritize
growth prioritize scale and most of all
engagement for the purpose of data
mining behavior and in turn selling all
that data for the purpose of perfect
targeted advertising as was so astutely
stated in the social dilemma documentary
we are not users of social media as much
as we are being used indeed we are the
product
unfortunately this model architected for
maximum engagement time spent on your
platform of choice has created a
pernicious misalignment of incentives
instead of creating a useful and healthy
experience for the end user what we
instead have are ecosystems very
specifically in scientifically designed
to hijack and addict our attention
highly sophisticated algorithms
encourage outraging conflict down
regulating sanity and instead upvoting
provocation when matched with the
addition of an endless scroll in the
dopamine-inducing anticipation of
external validation in the form of likes
comments and follows
the result is an extremely potent
narcotic that quite reliably deepens our
noxious and addictive relationship with
social media activates something Primal
in our lizard brain that overrides
rationality renders us powerless to set
it aside and over time obscures our
ability to evaluate situations
objectively and denigrates the Very
quality of Our Lives
social media with its utopic promise of
bringing the world closer as this
infinite repository of community and
wisdom has evolved beyond the Anodyne
era of using it to Simply stay in touch
with old friends into this potent
Crucible of division a mind virus that
erodes civility to instead reward our
most base and reactive impulses
a tool for bad faith actors to
manipulate at scale and we it's willing
denizens
but the real problem reveals itself when
the worst of these impulses and ideas
produced by the internet Escape their
digital confines make their way into the
analog world and produce very real very
negative consequences on the vulnerable
or undiscerning on those bereft of
critical thinking skills on the angry or
disenfranchised on our young and on our
Collective Consciousness as a whole
because in truth none of us are truly
immune
over time as the algorithms learn to
know us better than we know ourselves
our sources of information become
increasingly siled bespoke and highly
tailored to what we have most engaged
with historically
the result is both Distortion and
calcification a retreat into discrete
and isolated spaces of comfort that
entrench and affirm an already cemented
worldview and further solidify the
zero-sum game War of ideology
religion politics nutrition Sports the
subject itself matters less than the
sense of virtue produced by tribe
alignment a dopamine hit of superiority
experienced by shouting down the
opposing view as at best summarily wrong
and at worst downright evil as a result
constructive conversation is eroded it's
no longer about truth or even a good
faith attempt to listen let alone truly
understand our post-truth world isn't
about a collective effort to get get
things right it's about exacerbating the
fissures and fractures of Separation
it's about scoring points owning or
dunking on the other side when empathy
is so thoroughly supplanted with
righteousness as is most certainly the
case nobody wins
and together
we suffer
What Becomes of us when we can no longer
communicate constructively
when we can't tolerate an opposing
Viewpoint or when truth is irrelevant
conversation matters I say this often I
believe it to be true to my core and the
evolution that we desire the solutions
that we seek and desperately need to the
many problems we Face from the personal
to the global to the existential always
and in every instance begin with
conversation
in fact
conversation is truly all we have as a
bridge to a better self and a better
world
it's why I do this podcast it's why I
believe so urgently in the medium of
long-form conversational podcasting
but so much of what I would consider
real conversation a respectful good
faith exchange of perspective shared and
debated in a healthy Marketplace of
ideas has been denigrated on both social
and mainstream media to slinging
epithets on talk shows or incendiary
diatribes on Twitter and the Squawk Box
of sound bites shouting heads on cable
news competing for precious air time
he or she who shouts loudest and with
the greatest conviction wins a
competition that once again incentivizes
outrage and division at the cost of
shared values and at the cost of
appreciating that what unites us is far
greater and more important than the few
issues over which we squabble
and at the cost of creating healthy
resolution to the issues over which we
disagree for the betterment of all
this does not portend well for the
future of liberalism or the future of
democracy
for an open and free Society for
cultural cohesion or even our own
personal evolution
as a byproduct we've all borne witness
to the rapid deterioration of our Mental
Health
the human connection and Community
promised by our social media overlords
has instead and quite ironically
architected a deep sense of isolation
one in three Americans now identify as
lonely a statistic that rises to an
astonishing 61 percent among young
people one analysis likened the negative
effects of loneliness to smoking 15
cigarettes a day meanwhile rates of
depression continue to escalate this is
not to say that social media is entirely
to blame widening economic disparity the
pandemic and other factors certainly
shoulder responsibility but there is
something uniquely alarming
pernicious and perhaps even
Shakespearean about social media's
unique culpability as this instigating
accelerant in the Steep decline of
emotional well-being that we are
currently bearing witness to at scale
when quiet reflection in boredom the
sacred spaces for rumination have all
but been eradicated and replaced by the
impossible to deny urge to always be
scrolling we in turn welcome this
Poverty of creative expression uh
culture of instant impulsive reaction
over considered response a denigration
an agency and quite notably a
precipitous decline in mental health
produced by incessantly comparing the
quality of Our Lives to the endless feed
of idealization an onslaught of the most
curated polished versions of others and
their filtered performances skillfully
crafted to maximize external validation
and because we can't help but measure
ourselves against what we train our
attention on
we are willingly inviting a chronic
persistent state of feeling less than
into our lives a sense of
not being good enough of perhaps never
being able to be good enough because
comparison is the thief of joy in other
words the connection promised by every
login instead Engineers loneliness
depression chronic anxiety and a level
of Despair at just massive scale this
despair or loss of Hope
is in turn breeding and reinforcing a
global society that is becoming
increasingly bereft of empathy which is
a noxious emotional cocktail stoking
anger producing violence and rendering
millions of people vulnerable
vulnerable to self-harm
vulnerable to bad ideas
vulnerable to false promises false
narratives and false quick fixes to
happiness wealth Beauty romance fitness
health Serenity you name it
it's a predatory yet effective tactic
because pain let's face it is an easy
marketing Target and shortcut sell and
sell very well
so if you find yourself vulnerable to or
compelled by the quote secret truth they
don't want you to know and quote
carefully gated behind a paywall or the
click funnel email baiting you on the
newest Miracle Solution that's going to
Salve your wound or heal your pain or
render you attractive or give you six
back ABS or fill that unfillable hole in
your soul
please resist the temptation to bite and
just pause
step away
turn inward and try to locate
the source of that compulsion
what is the locus of your vulnerability
what is the nature and origin of the
whole that is seeking to be filled
and where and what is the why
behind the need
the answers all of us seek that sense of
wholeness
acceptance love compassion meaning
purpose and fulfillment
can't be found on the very same
platforms
that are contributing to that whole that
anxiety that depression loneliness and
despair that
too many people are experiencing and nor
will the answer be found in the job the
car the house or the Romantic partner
you're not going to find it in a
financial windfall or a psychedelic trip
and the work is not reading the latest
inspirational quote on your feed and it
certainly does not exist behind a
paywall
no the truth that you yearn for the
peace the self-love the sense of
direction of meaning
is much more complicated it's hard
earned it's messy it's non-linear it's
one step forward two steps back it's
very unique to you it's this process
without a destination it's incredibly
painful and hard and probably the most
difficult adventure of your life but
it's also
beautiful
and it's always always worth it
there is no one or right way to engage
with the inward journey of acceptance
healing and actualization and it's
really not my place to prescribe the
form your journey towards awareness
towards wholeness should take that's
yours and yours alone to struggle with
to determine to decide and ultimately
pursue but what I can offer are some
very basic and Simple Guide posts based
on experience
which I'll share with you with the
caveat that you uh very well may find
what follows
embarrassingly obvious or perhaps even
disappointingly but now in defense I
would argue that what might sound basic
and simple is in fact quite challenging
to practice with any modicum of
consistency and even with great
discipline would require a lifetime to
master so reflect on what resonates and
uh discard what doesn't as much as I'm
grateful for your attention my first
recommendation not shockingly is to log
off step away from the device
go outside create rules around the use
of your technology that provide ample
time and space to seek inward in other
words make room for boredom
I'd also like you to consider sobriety
or at least minimizing alcohol and other
mind-altering substances for the purpose
of cultivating clarity
because to numb oneself out
is to arrest growth in its tracks
prioritize quiet prioritize rest
prioritize sleep
and important one prioritize meditation
key and then take your mindfulness and
your mindfulness practice off the mat
and into the experience of your daily
life I encourage you to consciously
strive to be present even for the most
banal of moments and really connect more
deeply to your body what is it telling
you listen to the signals that it's
giving you pay attention particularly to
the faint Whispers especially when they
recur
what are they saying
I tend to hear them best with a slightly
elevated heart rate while alone in
nature
and consider them Messengers sacred foot
soldiers dispatched from my future
higher self they are catalysts for
transformation delivering magic when
translated into action
so listen to them and act upon them
and as you begin to connect more deeply
with yourself and your natural
surroundings allow yourself to be more
open and more vulnerable with a circle
of trusted friends
because what is hidden cannot be healed
it is in the light and the sharing and
the trust and the vulnerability that
together we get better
and because we Are Spiritual Beings
having a human experience it's my belief
that engaging with the spirituality of
your choosing through prayer ceremony or
other means that you discover or become
comfortable with is really
Paramount
journaling another obvious but important
big one challenging to do with
consistency but so crucial in terms of
connecting with and being in
relationship with and indulging your
creativity and taking it out of the
journal into the world to give yourself
permission to
be creative to express yourself to build
something to make something to share
something
is a great practice
another great practice practicing random
acts of kindness practicing them until
they become reflexive cultivating
gratitude by making a handwritten list
each day of things you are thankful for
seek out all seek out wonder by both
investing in unique experiences but also
by just identifying it in your everyday
lives
when you're present and you're noticing
you can find awe and wonder
in everything
practice becoming an excellent listener
not just to yourself but to others
because the greatest gift that you can
give another is your attention it's a
gift that will be rewarded tenfold
pursue joy and finally find a way to be
of service to others
preferably that also channels that
connection with joy because we all have
something of value to give and acting on
it unlocks the door to purpose
the list of obvious things we don't
adequately honor or practice as long I
could go on and I should add before
closing that everything I am expressing
here is a needed reminder to myself as
much as to you because I am certainly no
master and so to end I want to really
encourage all of you to find the
strength find the fortitude
to go inward or to go further inward to
push past the fear that keeps your pain
private to reckon with your demons and
your Darkness
and expose them to the light
and heal
because
you deserve the peace and the freedom
and the Fulfillment that will bring and
because
what you discover along the way will be
of tremendous value when shared with
others
and because the rest of us not just your
family and your friends but truly the
world needs the best most fully
actualized version of you
now
more than ever
meanwhile
have more conversations real
conversations old school campfire
conversations
because conversation
matters
thank you for listening thank you for
indulging me in this experiment I hope
you found it of some value and uh I'll
see you back here in a couple days
peace
plants
[Music]